>>> WE WELCOME YOU BACK TO
"INSIDE THE NBA" PRESENTED BY
KIA.
THE FIRST GAME WE HAD ON
TONIGHT, THE KNICKS AND THE
HAWKS, IT WAS GREAT TO HAVE MARV
ALBERT ACTUALLY AT THE GAME.
>> 100%.
>> WHAT A GREAT PLACE TO DO IT,
MADISON SQUARE GARDEN WHERE HE'S
HAD SO MANY ICONIC CALLS IN THE
HISTORY OF HIS LONG CAREER.
HE REMINISCED A BIT AFTER THE
GAME.
>> THE MOMENT THAT STANDS OUT TO
ME GOES BACK TO WHEN YOU WERE
JUST A LITTLE KID.
>> OKAY.
>> IF THAT.
>> YES.
>> 1970 WHEN THE KNICKS, I WAS
DOING RADIO FOR THE KNICKS, WON
THEIR FIRST NBA CHAMPIONSHIP
WHEN PEOPLE DID NOT EXPECT THAT
REED WOULD PLAY BECAUSE HE WAS
INJURED BUT HE TOOK A SHOT
BEFORE THE GAME AND CAME OUT
AFTER THE KNICKS PLAYERS HAD
FINISHED THEIR WARMUPS.
HE WALKED OUT UNDER THE COURT.
THAT WAS THE LOUDEST I HAVE EVER
HEARD.
>> TO THIS DAY?
>> YES, MADISON SQUARE GUARDEN.
OR ANY CROWD.
WE'RE NOT COURT SIDE, BUT WE
HAVE A GREAT LOCATION.
AND IT'S SO DIFFERENT THAN WHAT
IT USED TO BE.
BUT IT IS A THRILL TO ME.
I RESPECT THE FACT THAT THE
ATLANTA HAWKS HAD A GREAT YEAR
AND THE KNICKS WERE SURPRISING.
THINGS HAVE NOT GONE AS WELL FOR
THE KNICKS OVER THE LAST 21
YEAR